[Musique]
nous sommes à Paris en 1992
bien installé au Train Bleu le mythique
Café de la Gare de Lyon
je suis avec ma fille je jouis des
derniers moments que nous allons passer
ensemble nous sommes silencieuses
tout à coup Rachel me dit maman tu sais
tu n'es pas un exemple pour les femmes
j'ai failli renverser mon café
comment ça ben oui depuis toujours tu me
dis d'oser d'avoir le courage d'aller au
bout de mon rêve d'être danseuse à
l'Opéra de Paris j'y suis
un peu grâce à toi
moi je la regarde des emparés elle a les
larmes au bord des yeux
qu'est-ce qu'il y a ma chérie qu'est-ce
que tu veux me dire
et ben oui depuis toujours
tu fais tout pour moi regarde tu viens à
Paris dès que j'ai un petit bobo
je me sens coupable je me sens coupable
parce que toi aussi tu as mes rêves
et que à cause de moi et de mon frère tu
attends
mais tu attends quoi tu vas avoir 46 ans
si tu ne le fais pas maintenant tu le
feras quand et puis je me sens aussi
coupable parce que tu me donnes le
sentiment que je dois me sacrifier pour
Pierre
on est tous les deux à l'Opéra et je
vois bien à l'Opéra comme dans la vie
c'est toujours la fin qui sacrifie son
rêve ses projets ce qu'elle a envie de
faire regarde mon ami Julie son mari a
trouvé une place dans le Midi et puis
elle est en deuxième année de médecine
elle peut pas continuer ses études
là-bas
moins maman je ne veux pas me sacrifier
depuis mes 7 ans je fais tout pour
arriver à l'Opéra j'y suis je veux
devenir danseuse étoile je veux pas me
sacrifier
là je suis là
mon Dieu tu as vu l'heure
on court sur le quai je saute dans le
TGV les portes se ferment j'entends
Rachel mon ange je t'aime
moi aussi ma chérie
dans le TGV je vois la Douce France
défiler à 150 à l'heure et moi je pense
à ma vie à mon destin suspendu à 15 ans
j'ai quitté l'école pour seconder ma
maman veuve dans son commerce
à 18 ans j'avais un diplôme de commerce
à 22 ans je me suis mariée
et j'ai commencé des études pour passer
une maturité fédérale scientifique
je l'ai passé et j'ai directement
enchaîné sur une formation artistique
je trouvais ma voix
j'ai 32 ans quand Rachel me dit maman je
vais être danseuse
et je décide de m'engager pour l'aider à
y arriver
alors je décide de reprendre des études
et à 36 ans
je m'inscris à l'école d'ingénieur de
Vienne et à 40 ans je suis la première
femme en Suisse diplômée en informatique
de l'école d'ingénieur de Vienne je suis
directement engagée pour lancer les
modes flic flac
je deviens madame Flix c'est un succès
trois ans plus tard je passe dans une
grande marque du groupe où je suis
responsable des nouveaux produits
et tout ça en m'engageant tout le temps
pour la cause des femmes
je trouve que c'est pas si mal que ça
comment elle peut dire ça Rachel
le train fil arrive à Lure le regard au
loin perdu dans mes pensées
au fond Rachel elle a peut-être un peu
raison
depuis toujours
tout ce que je fais
est fonction
des exigences de ma famille
je les aide je les accompagne je les
soutiens je suis toujours là pour eux
parfois je pense aussi
un peu à moi
pas très longtemps
pourtant moi aussi j'ai un rêve
si ma mission
c'est d'aider les autres
ma passion c'est la création
depuis longtemps je désire créer quelque
chose de très beau à la gloire des
femmes
un objet unique et merveilleux
qui les accompagne
et les soutiens pour réaliser leurs
rêves
j'ai cherché très longtemps
jusqu'à ce que le destin vienne à mon
secours j'ai été engagée dans
l'horlogerie à ce moment j'ai su ce que
j'allais faire créer une montre
qui symbolise le temps des femmes
une montre qui a un sens pour la femme
qui la porte
j'ai développé un concept toujours
unique
j'ai créé une montre au design
merveilleuse
avec une symbolique universelle
une véritable petite sculpture
symbole du courage de la créativité des
femmes
j'arrive à la maison et cette
conversation avec Rachel me tourne dans
la tête
se passe quelques mois
lorsqu'un événement inattendu va me
donner le coup de pied nécessaire
c'était en le 3 mars 1993 peut-être que
certains d'entre vous s'en souviennent
élection au Conseil fédéral
Christiane Brunner n'est pas élu
je suis furieux
hors de moi
comment une femme aussi engagée aussi
brillante reste sur le carreau
il n'y a pas de mots je ne les trouve
pas d'ailleurs
c'est tragique c'est tragique pour les
femmes mais c'est ridicule de la part
des hommes qui ne l'ont pas aidé qui ne
l'ont pas élu
et moi à ma colère
j’arpente mon balcon
j'admire les Alpes du sentis jusqu'au
Mont Blanc
je suis furieuse ces Alpes immobile mais
moi je peux je dois bouger je dois faire
quelque chose mais que faire pour
changer les choses
quelqu'un a dit
si tu veux changer le monde
commence par toi-même
c'est évident
je dois me réaliser et réaliser mon rêve
en ce printemps
1993 je démarre
je fais le compte de mes atouts
je suis intelligente en bonne santé j'ai
l'esprit d'entreprise je suis créative
et j'en passe
et puis
j'ai l'audace
de réaliser mon rêve mais pas la
témérité
j'ai toutes les qualités d'un
entrepreneur d'une entreprise
et j'ai aussi
à qui
tout ce que je devais savoir pour créer
mon entreprise
en 1996
je décide de créer de lance
à cette époque là j'ai 50 ans
et logique toute féminine je lui donne
le nom de mon père
de l'anse a maintenant 27 ans
j'ai surmonté
bien des problèmes j'ai fait ce ne fut
pas un long fleuve tranquille
j'ai failli être noyé submergé
disparaître
mais en bonne nageuse j'ai toujours
réussi à monter le courant
et de là c'est toujours là
et moi avec
avec de lance
j'ai voyagé sur tous les continents
partout j'ai observé la condition des
femmes
partout les femmes sont en mouvement et
petit à petit elle contient leur droit
mais
il y a encore beaucoup à faire
c'est le moment d'enclencher question de
démocratie la vitesse supérieure
qu'ai-je retiré
de ce défi de ce challenge
d'abord je me suis découverte
et j'ai appris un nombre incroyable de
choses j'ai surmonté des épreuves
je suis peut-être devenu qui j'étais
tout au fond depuis si longtemps
donc je doutais que je ne savais pas
mesdames messieurs
de l'audace encore de l'audace toujours
de l'audace
et vous découvrirez qui vous êtes et ce
que vous êtes capable de faire
vous éprouvez aussi
la joie
que donne le courage la joie de vous
réaliser
ayez aussi la générosité
et l'audace
d'aider celles et ceux qui ont un rêve
et vous en ferez partie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]